we begin with big breaking news it's
official Kanye West turning Hollywood in
the liberal music world upside down
pledging his full-throated support and
love for president Trump the rapper it
sweetie you don't have to agree with
Trump but the mob can't make me not love
him
we are both dragon energy he is my
brother I love everyone I don't agree
with everything anyone does that's what
makes us individuals and we have the
right to independent thought he also
tweeted a selfie and a maggot hat well
as you can imagine his support is
appreciated by the president Trump
responding to the rapper on Twitter
writing Thank You Kanye very cool Sarah
Sanders was even asked about it at the
press briefing today seriously on the
news lately for supporting the president
expressing his admiration for the
president the president has reached out
to Kanye West and whether he'd be
willing to meet with them at the White I
don't know of any conversation that
they've had over the last week or so
I'll keep you posted if that change is a
time that's I know they met during the
transition that's the only meeting I'm
aware of that's taking place or
conversation and that's we said on the
show yesterday met at over Trump Tower
transition time but needless to say the
internet freaking out over this with
comments like I never needed a photo of
Kanye with a Maggie hat on and I still
don't and then Donald Trump and Kanye
speaking over Twitter welcomed the 2018
so does everyone believe this is legit
or is this the ultimate trolling going
on Gregg you have some answers not all
of you know I know that this this is
actually a bigger deal than just what's
happening on Twitter it's it's a big
deal because what you're seeing is
you're collapsing of a world of
conventional assumptions where people
are supposed to stay in their boxes and
if you get out of your box there is
generally an online mob that will come
after you for your political beliefs or
any beliefs and what he's doing right
now
which is kind of inspirational and I
actually do think it's a big it's a
fairly big deal it's bigger than the
Roseanne bang this guy's 18 million
followers and they watch E and Bravo
this is a world that like it's it's a
different world that he's reaching out
to and it's kind of heroic when when I
know personally musicians and actors who
just regular people who are punished for
offering a counter-narrative any kind of
counter narrative and he's basically
standing up and he's saying I'll take
the slings and arrows I'm okay with it
I'm big enough I returned to the Candace
Owen thing when he defended her he was
supporting her not for ideas but for her
guts and he was still targeted which
shows that there's a there is a mob out
there that wants to silence you if you
leave your box and what he's doing and
what a lot of people are doing classical
liberals from the Dave Reubens and the
and the Sam Harris's and the Joe Rogan's
in the podcast world they are leaving
their boxes and they're daring people to
come with them they'll you know it is
it's people are leaving the intellectual
conformity and he's he's I don't know
he's celebrating it the tweets are a
celebration I think all right fantastic
so Dina welcome back thanks I haven't
been here I think look I've got a
personal feeling about Kanye West and
what he said about george w bush during
katrina was outrageous and maybe he
wouldn't say that again today but it was
a terrible thing to do to somebody and
actually what would have been really
brave would have been going after the
real culprits as in the local and state
government that did not help the
african-american people of New Orleans
absolutely and so I'll just leave that
there I also think and in addition all
the things that Gregg said I think it's
a great way to get publicity before your
album comes out you know 100 percent so
that's the is this sad I don't I'm not
saying that it's not real or not
checking I think I think it can be both
that the timing could be sure no
auspicious I don't think he needs
publicity for his albums maybe so pretty
well on their own jesse also welcome
back yes did a great job yesterday thank
you
nice apron thank you very much so all
right so what do you make of this you
know because it's true he was there we
showed the footage yesterday in the
beginning part of the show that he was
at Trump Tower is a transition he was
expressive then welcoming and meeting
with the president and felt like he was
at the time candidate Trump but you know
felt that he was listening to his voice
wanted to talk and do outreach there's
nothing wrong with that so what is this
an extension of it or is there something
else going on or combination I'm not as
cynical as Dana you know I'm a little
more hopeful for Kanye I think Kanye's
matured since he said what he said about
george w bush at katrina and i think he
would agree now the new loving kanye
would look back on that and probably not
like that because he also said he loves
hillary and i think he's trying to lean
forward with love and not say you know
if I like this person it doesn't mean I
hate their opponent and I can't say it
any better than Greg Gutfeld just said I
think that was perfect I think you can't
underestimate what's going on here
culturally politically and he's
shattering the paradigm of us against
them of the tribes we're all against
each other we hate each other and it's a
new phenomenon because people have not
really expressed themselves like this
you've never seen someone at this level
of the celebrity shock and awe the
public to such an extent where people
are going what is happening he must be
mentally ill yeah that's what he has
said something that has blown people's
minds they actually think he needs to
see a doctor and remember that's what
they said about Trump because he's got
so much dragon blood or whatever he
sounds like Charlie Sheen once in a
while people come along and they break
the mold Kanye is one of them Donald
Trump is one of them he breaks the
conventional wisdom and let's also
remember black Americans not all of them
black Americans liked Donald Trump
before he became a politician you've
seen pictures of him he was you know in
the boxing game he was out you know at
nighttime taking lots of pictures with
other celebrities and people admired his
entrepreneurship his flashiness
is style and his wealth and the women
that he hung around with and things
changed when he became political but he
was admired for that by a lot of people
in different communities and now the
fact that he's come out
you know he said some things that have
angered people in the black community
yeah that doesn't mean you you can't
change as a person doesn't mean you know
you have to leave that person but I
think Trump has matured and by that you
mean the wonderful you know wives that
he has had New York Society for many
many years
yes all right okay so on have you
recovered from Jesse I'm trying my best
but I think this is such a superficial
conversation because I think Kanye West
is the same guy that as Dana said was
insulting Republicans a minute ago in a
way that I thought was unfair and now he
comes back and I guess it's always gonna
be a market for people who say well oh
but now he likes Trump so we're gonna
rally to come well look even his wife
said hey Kanye you don't agree with all
of his policy in the Connie way so yeah
that's true but it doesn't matter cuz I
also like Hillary but it doesn't matter
I like somebody's policies
he's got the dragon energy or the drag
whatever and you know it's just so silly
at a time when in America we've got like
you know black women on a golf course in
Pennsylvania being the police call to
get him off or the Starbucks situation
or the young man who was shot in his
grandmother's backyard in Sacramento and
instead of focusing on like real issues
impacting race in our country we're
focusing on Kanye West who says it's not
about anything of substance it's just
all of a sudden with a record coming out
he likes Donald Trump so I guess all the
Donald Trump folks that will go by Kanye
West records but I mean that's that's
the kind of response that Kanye expects
which is to dismiss his beliefs this is
what happens if you step out of a box
somebody's gonna accuse you of
opportunism they're gonna bring up your
past they're gonna tell you that you're
you know you're probably just just some
kind of you know marketer that's what
happens he knows that we're here I think
your analysis is way off here this is
not about stepping out of a box what I'm
saying to you is if this guy was like
Supreme Court Justice Thomas if he was
Tom's soul if he was someone who was
making his own sortie if he was someone
who was making a substantive argument
right about how Donald Trump in fact is
a beneficial for
in American life especially in terms of
black people and that black people
haven't all been brave quarrel with what
he said because you don't like the way
he's entitled like everybody at this but
he still if somebody who's an
entrepreneur
and somebody who's been very
successfully he's now a fan of Donald
Trump where'd this come paddled to his
opinion sure what difference does great
when Roseanne get it now we don't
Donald Trump but it's more about with
the candice owens thing he's celebrating
people for being independent thinker
right you expect someone like candice
Owens from her demographic young black
female in America to think the way a lot
of the other young black female in
America think about Donald Trump and
that's usually about ninety percent one
way she's celebrating her bravery he's
celebrating her independence of thought
and stepping out of the box and standing
up to the mob who comes after her for
saying something that a lot of people in
her group don't believe in so this is
more about groupthink than breaking
through that and celebrating people this
is my vigil ally in aggression this is
what Gregory was saying but what I'm
saying to you is it's not about
groupthink
if Candace Owens or Kanye want to make
an argument I'm glad to hear it but
that's not what they're saying what
they're saying I mean it's like John
legend today tweeted out this thing
about stop calling the cops will you're
on black people and so now everybody
says oh that's a racist comment because
blacks have a higher crime etc but you
stop and think about it Jesse if you and
I are walking down the street and some
cops that beat me in the head you're
gonna say what weight is it why you're
hitting one I understand that this isn't
just about yeah listen it's just let
people have their own opinions and their
viewpoints it what makes this country
diverse and it shouldn't matter what
skin color you have you shouldn't adopt
a certain ideology or philosophy and
then be criticized and bashed by other
people I think it's very unfair